salut à tous on se retrouve pour une
petite partie de pêche aliments au bord
du canal du midi
donc c'est une vidéo qui a été tournée
il ya pas mal de temps on a monté
récemment on a aussi ajouté donc à cette
vidéo la restauration des objets trouvés
et vous allez voir qu'on a aussi été
confronté à deux riverains un peu
mécontents
on attaque tout de suite et ça commence
avec du lourd
certainement
la première vieux un enrouleur mais en
fait il semblerait que ce soit plutôt
une une [ __ ] d'amarrage pour les pour
les péniches on a trouvé ça aussi donc
c'est sûrement un goût de deux couleurs
peut être un peu lourd en panne ce genre
de choses
allez on continue
pas mal de branches ici mais on va les
sortir quand même ça fera déjà c'est en
moins d'un an et on s'accrochera plus
dessus
[Musique]
un vélo
vous
[Musique]
l'élu fait pas le voc
mais des éléments
on envoie des aimants puissant et haut
rang que les autres voilà pour le vélo
donc de marco nakamura
c'est vraiment parce que le pneu vin est
encore gonflé le reste il reste un peu
d'air
il y en a nous opérons alors ça il
semblerait que ce soit un ou l' objet en
donc au moins dix huitième siècle
poteau en fer
[Musique]
leur mobile
tu peux pas initier un petit ce qu'il en
reste on voyage
[Musique]
en commun et en plus
mon épaule et on ramasse des méthodes
je crois que ce type est fou à lier
je pense qu'ils se prend pour h vanier
[Musique]
on dépollue canal des métaux un petit
peu tout y'a pas de soucis
on se retrouve après cette pêche dans
mon jardin pour l'analyse des
trouvailles j'ai retrouvé le calibre de
l'adulte trouvait il s'agit de 20 x 138
mm allemand utilisé pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale en tant qu'art anti-char
et anti-aérien
par chance j'avais déjà un fusil et
charles dans ma remise pour dsk la
munition au le renouveau ici on est
inquiet voilà donc on a lavé le vélo
dans la rivière on attaque tout de suite
avec sa restauration
petite vidéo de la restauration dont on
a tout ce qu'il faut là plus important
c'est le wd commencent à nettoyer
on va enlever la roue arrière il est
déjà un petit peu mieux mais encore du
boulot
la base à faire
[Musique]
oh